pour passer le temps de temps à autre
les amants se font à poutre de nos rêves
d'enfants
l'un à l'autre il se promène sans faute
de n'être qu'en rien
celui seulement qui reste qui attend
RA
votre bien
mon amour
faire un tour les jardins qui nous
promettent
on désire
Bauer
où l'on pourrait se dire je t'aime
tout simplement
oui pour passer le temps de temps à vous
les amants se font à votre de nos rêves
d'enfants
on l'a quand l'heure devient
secondé comme on tient vraiment
il se tiennent le par la main
ce jour sans fin
mon amour
faire un tour les jardins qui nous
promènent
en désert
bohème où l'on pourrait se dire je
t'aime
t'aime simplement
mon amour
faire un tour les jardins qui nous
promènent on desserre
où l'on pourrait se dire
tout simplement
allez viens
mon amour
faire un tour
des jardins qui nous promène
on désire
moment
où l'on pourrait se dire je t'aime
tout simplement
mon amour
faire un tour
des jardins qui nous promènent on désire
bohème
où l'on pourrait se dire je t'aime
tout simplement
oui tout simple
Didier Sustrac qui a notamment